les agents alors c'est quoi c'est ce que
je vais faire je vous faire danser déjà
quelqu'un du public ce soir voilà si
botul à aller je vois qu'ils vont
annoncer à gagny tu me danseurs et manie
la bonne année
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
bonjour comment elle va celle-ci balle
va bien comment il s'appelle elle
s'appelle nadine nadine j'aime bien
alors là qu'est ce qu'on a fait là à
bâtir ici j'aime beaucoup j'ai pris moi
elle et ses cheveux sont coupés remous
j'adore ça s'hérite hamida que tammy
quad la cocotte avec qua non d'amico a
rien c'est naturel j'aime bien dis donc
tu as fait tu fais quoi dans la vie je
suis fière de vente à pondre à tout ça
pour nora pendant alors on est obligé de
citer amener d'autres d'autres marques
de bijoux bien sûr qu'il va chuter
agathe espoirs d'or de bijoux pics
belgique se réjouissent également le
magasin de bijoux c'est astérix ya des
ménés au nord de bagdad où six malades
mais je dis que tu es marié tuant ses
fiancés il est là oui il est dans le
public
donc c'est qu'ils aient levé vous
monsieur il est
bouge pas trop ça mais je vois là comme
ça on va être défonce tout défoncer
stovall laisse tomber il fait quoi dans
la vie careem carim effet qu'on a envie
bigland ils vont jouer en ligue 1 alors
on a des propositions dans ce que
voulait chanter ce que voulaient danser
avec maxime gagné sur matt pokora les
planètes sur russell [ __ ] sur shy'm
sur worlds appart ou sur kenzy à
lézinnes qui dit que tu allais les
worlds apart à c'est là qu'on connaît le
modernisme la modernité
[Applaudissements]
bras
hélas
[Applaudissements]
pas que ça
[Musique]
bien
franchement il a il a beaucoup donné en
achetant bassil a beaucoup donné matière
à temps qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu
veux tout faire comme cadeau qu'ils
étaient en vie que tu veux rien si j'ai
bien sûr elles n'ont pas du tout moi je
t'offre un allez je t'offre une console
de jeux vidéo c'est bon car himself et
plérin
[Applaudissements]